see that the adidas boob tweet that was
the thing okay i think we got her i
think we got our guest uh here
um brian is that is that you brian hi uh
brian salve how you doing uh how are you
brian uh
great great great yeah i just wanted i
just wanted to come on and uh okay yeah
and and give my two cents here uh oh
well we're we're
my my audience is ready for you to give
your two cents everyone have their
comments ready here
um for for brian yeah this is your
opportunity i just want to uh explain
myself okay i'm good you know as a man
okay as a as a as a strong man as a
strong man of christ
yes um
i just want to defend myself
and tell you that i'm right uh and
everyone else is wrong
okay uh i
uh you know i'm uh i i'm a man of god a
man of christ um you know what i say is
not to be uh taken in vain um but should
be followed
for uh we are the children of christ
and it is what christ would want uh
these women to not uh share these photos
of themselves so so brian so brian let
me ask you um
you say you're a man and you're a man's
man yeah are you are you terrified of
women because it really seems like
you're terrified no no no i'm not
are you scared of boobs because it it
seems like you're either really scared
of women or you're really scared of
boobs why would you
why would you even say something like
that
like what that you're scared of boobs
yeah why would you why where did you
even get that idea well i mean you tweet
a lot about how you don't want to see
women's skin and that you okay it's like
you're okay like why am i now the victim
okay why are you coming after me
it's like that's not very christ-like of
you to attack a fellow
i'm not i i i'm not i am i'm not i'm not
a christian so well well hopefully
hopefully you will repent for your sins
and and uh and you'll find the way of
christ but i don't appreciate being
attacked here i i don't appreciate uh
being uh the victim um of this onslaught
attack onslaught of what you know you
posted the tweet on twitter you said it
i was speaking for god
god spoke god he spoke through me
yeah so yeah so if god speaks through
you through your tweets what makes you
think that the the uh the boob tweets
that women post aren't speaking through
god i mean i kind of like that god
better than your god i'm just saying
it's it it makes me feel uncomfortable
okay boobs make you feel uncomfortable
or the fact that the boob god is better
than your god
there's a boob god well i mean i'm just
assuming i i don't believe in god but
you do and i'm saying yes i do i do
believe in god you said that god's your
god speaks through you with the tweets
i'm just saying maybe there's a big guy
his spirit speaks through me i don't
know anything about a boob god if there
was a boob god i would say he was the
devil himself satan
satan it's antichrist it's possible that
satan is the boob god but i mean you
know heaven or hell i'm going with the
boob god over your god who doesn't want
women to be able to okay okay
you know what next we're just gonna give
everyone the equal rights right like
women are just all of a sudden are gonna
be do whatever they want they can just
like vote
yet they can vote what yes they can they
can vote yep that's probably your
problem here is that you're you're in a
different timeline when did that happen
when did this happen this is this has
been a while ago brian and and honestly
not only can they vote they can have
twitter accounts too it's a thing that
women can do like it's a it's a liberty
that is given to i'm going to focus i'm
going to have to pray on this i'm going
to have to pray on this pray what are
you praying for what do you bring for
for for god to forgive them forgive them
for what for
thinking thinking that they can that
they are
mightier than man
so you're mad that women are can be more
powerful than men
it's like how many ways do i have to put
it okay i i i don't i don't know i'm
trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
you're trying to say women make me feel
uncomfortable
okay
why is why do they make you feel are you
do you not like women i love i love my
wife i love my wife okay i love my wife
i don't i if i love my wife i i i love
that's that's a sign that i love women
okay i love my wife
so just because you you say you love
your wife means that you love all women
is that what you're saying this is
duh it's like
i'm a feminist okay how are you women
yeah
you heard it here folks you heard it
here folks brian here is a is a feminist
um you know
so why then don't you want women to
express
their feelings and their bodies okay you
know what i feel like i've had enough
questions i feel like i'm being
persecuted like jesus christ himself
you're gonna put me on the cross and
just make me face all of these people
for judgment i don't think so you know
god forgive me for they know not what
they do okay that is what i have to say
to you you know yes women make me feel
uncomfortable okay there's a lot of
temptation a lot of temptation in my
pants okay tommy and i got to tell you
this it makes me super uncomfortable
that when i have to look at them online
that that that they're able to express
themselves in a way that i can't okay
that they're able to be free and they're
able to
just just just be who they are okay and
i i don't feel like i should be uh the
the the victim this attack uh that all
of these these these people are coming
at me for um but you know what i will
prevail i am a messenger of christ and a
messenger of god and i will tell you
this much that when more people come at
me it only makes me stronger
well i i i appreciate that you think
that your weakness makes you strong
because it definitely is a weakness for
you and i i regret i regret putting you
as a contestant on the bone of the week
i definitely think you should have been
our alpha cuck of the week so brian i
really appreciate you stopping by
and um maybe we'll get gabe back here to
uh get his opinion on it thanks thanks
brian oh thanks a lot yeah pray for me
okay well while we while we wait to see
if we can bring gabe back in the studio
um let's go to
let's go to
the
um the actual uh
thread here for brian you can see um
here that let's see oh wait wait wait a
second we got the twitter down see i'm
i'm all over the place he had me really
distracted completely distracted there
um of what he was trying to do so here's
the here's the oh
here's the oh they want me to sign in oh
my gosh
okay so here is
twitter is still down okay so here's the
brian
suave there's two of them look
salve there's two of them see that
there's two of them
oh here here's gabe back what do you
think of this guy would you like to do
this game sorry did you were able to i i
patched through i don't know if you guys
yeah yeah you weren't there but we got
him through we got him he's great great
okay yeah well not great but yeah i mean
i wasn't able to create through uh yeah
he's he's a [ __ ] bonehead and he
definitely i'm and again i'm and kind of
said we put him in his contestant not
the alpha cuck of the week i told him
that at the end
um you see there's two of these guys
now
obviously you know it's hard to confuse
um brian the one that was just on the
show here the christian pastor husband
father of five and classical school
founder what the [ __ ] does that mean
uh what is that i don't know what that
means i don't know
but there's another one um the new
christian dom oh christian sounds like a
cult a cultic cult cult um but then uh
there's another one president of the
national police federation i don't know
that sounds like a better guy right
right
i like i don't know about brian salves
in the world but two of them sound like
pretty shitty people oh that that see
that's why we can't go on this feed see
now i'm gonna have to blur on youtube
this guy
have you seen the
adidas tweet i have you i have yeah and
what did you think in the adidas tweet
more problem to them you know make that
[ __ ] feel uncomfortable obviously you
can't show it on here but you know
there's a okay i will say this there is
a lot of stuff on twitter uh
that you stumble across
um
you know and um
but more yeah more power to adidas to to
share that you know empowering women to
say like you know not all women are the
same and everyone is different and
unique and these are the bodies that
we've been given by god
and you should uh you should feel
empowered you should feel uh
special you should feel you know okay to
to to be yourself you know don't feel
ashamed um
of
of uh of who you are
well right uh you know and if you go
through that feed because uh
that the the reason why we know who this
guy is because he posted something like
women shouldn't post pictures of their
skin they shouldn't post weight loss
journey pictures they shouldn't post
pregnancy journey pictures and the other
day we actually showed a
a tweet where um kalyn i believe um
called him out on it and he posted a
picture of his of his wife while she was
pregnant on his the same account that he
was posting oh that's right yeah yeah
yeah so the hypocrite crazy well yeah oh
who would have thought so but but the
the the point is is that that this guy
this guy just wants to hate women um
yeah that's what these alpha cuts well
they just want control right they want
to control women your body
my choice my choice yep that's right
that's right speaking of speaking of
your body my choice let's go let's go to
um
let's go to um the uh alpha cuck let's
do alphacut first
we
we need to have a sound effect for that
i know i don't know if
it's going to be childish or should like
elf i think it should be like alpha